well I think first thing when one looks
back of all the presidencies I looked at
it seemed to me this was the most
coherent foreign policy team then they
were sort of working together they were
more or less like-minded of what they
were trying to achieve I was probably
the pinnacle of American prestige in the
reason after the defeat of Iraq in the
in the first gulf war after the liberal
after they'd occupied he waited in the
United States pushed them out a lot of
flaws of the of the elder Bush
administration but but that achievement
in itself and whatever one thinks now
about not getting rid of Saddam Hussein
at the time the when they had the chance
at the time this was considered to be
responsible and restrained and a very
statesman like Iran Bush's part in left
him with enormous prestige now I think
he saw that this was the time to try to
move forward the arab-israeli conflict
and with James Baker they took a pretty
tough line with shamir who was then
prime minister who was also a liquid
Nick like like like bagan but actually
more hardline in some ways even than
bayad and extraordinarily very stubborn
man and I think they have maneuvered him
to the point where he lost an election
and yet sakura beam came in and i think
the sort of the poignancy for the for
the bush administration that bush
administration was that they just got to
themselves to the point where they were
able to build on some foreign policy
achievements when when the election came
and bush removing James Baker from being
Secretary of State when he was really
made of quite a considerable figure to
run his campaign
meant that that momentum was lost in
there of course Bush being defeated
meant it was lost altogether but I think
you can see in 91 92 real American
political muscle in the region and the
framework being said for taking issues
forward into the community can also
critical that the other great advantage
of the soviet union with just
evaporating and withdrawing from the
scene so that the the old bull walk of
the radicals which was support from
Moscow was suddenly nowhere to be found
a name was incredibly vulnerable is
result I think the inter father was a
moment of truth for Israeli politics in
that they suddenly realized that they
couldn't instead of having arafat it was
sort of an old-style NASA NASA right
radical secular people had remembered
him you know with the gun in one hand
the always walked round in battle
fatigues and so on the terrorism of the
eighties among all this associations of
the Palestinians in the 80s I've been
pretty negative associated with
terrorism with uncompromising attitudes
towards Israel as unyielding and if the
Israelis feel look tough in response it
was well you know the Palestinians asked
for it then all of a sudden you have
from within the territories kids
throwing stones having demonstrations
and the Israelis really beating down on
them and causing enormous tensions
within Israeli society itself yeah it
was really is having real doubts as to
where they were doing and what would
what they were doing and could they
sustain that and so on so I think the
first test was for Israel itself and i
think was out of that that success
someone like Robin is a very good
example realize that they couldn't go
like that I think the American
administration I was often the case I
think with Bush well I started it
started under Reagan picked it up I mean
that they saw what was going on but then
of course the effects were to some
extent counted because the Palestinians
handled the gulf war itself so badly
Arafat supported Saddam became almost
the sort of core tier of Saddam based
himself in Baghdad and that lost the
Palestinians not only ground with the
Americans but with the rest of the Arab
world and then you have the
extraordinary exodus of Jews from the
collapsing Soviet Union which reinforced
Israel on its demographics so I think
the the effects of the intifada or
probably recognized more within Israel
and and had a shift in Israeli opinion
perhaps more than they did for the
Americans who got moved on destructive
to everything there's two separate
issues with the end of the world so
there was never an intention to go to
Baghdad for all the reasons that we now
understand that if you did that there
would be responsible for him they didn't
want to be responsible and they were
worried it would break up and that the
radians would benefit and and so on so
forth so that there were clear reasons
why they didn't want to go to Baghdad
themselves but they did want to see the
end of Saddam Hussein and they thought
he would go and that leads to the second
issue which is actually how you finished
the war the thing about the Gulf War in
91 was it ended very quickly and it
ended because the Americans had rather
in the laboratory tack white tough enemy
which involved in circling them and
cutting off the Republican Guard and so
on so that Saddam would lose the bulwark
of his regime but instead of that almost
as soon as the Marines move forward
towards Kuwait City which is supposed to
be just to a probe
thing the Iraqi resistance crumbled so
the whole choreography of the war went
wrong it was too easy in a sense so
while the you know the the US army was
so trundling round in this great
encirclement movement the Iraqis were
charging open when the Americans
attacked they're retreating Iraqis it
looked like they were setting up for
sort of them a bloodbath or turkey
shooting was called and the consequences
of that was the war ended very abruptly
and but that allowed sedam to say launch
the Americans of ashford call the
ceasefire not us and the Americans
realized the enormous strength that they
were good that they were facing from
from the Republican Guards so he didn't
have to accept it as a defeat though it
clearly was but he got a lot of his
people back that was a problem secondly
instead of and what the Americans hoped
whether it was that there be a coup that
there'd be some general would say you've
read us into disaster this is what you
this is how you've kept Powell this is
how you gotta lose power and shot him
they thought something like that would
happen but it said there was an
insurrection and the Shiite areas and
the Kurdish areas and the Americans
didn't even give a hint they would
support this they stood back and when
that happened Saddam use that to crush
the insurrection but our two
consequences first it made the the
Sunnis saw him as their protector it
strengthened the regime and its hour of
greatest need because he was the one who
was able to sustain the Sunni position
secondly it created a sense of American
responsibility for the curtain to a
lesser extent the Shiites so that's
where he got the no-fly zones from and
and so on so that although the Americans
have made a strategic decision not to
get involved in Iraqi internal affairs
there they were involved in Iraqi
internal affairs responsible for the
northern Iraq in
in many ways and they could never
extricate themselves from that obviously
haven't to this day so I think the all
wars all was then tend to end in and
expected in messy ways and that there is
unfortunately a history of never quite
preparing for their aftermath I don't
think that the lack of preparation for
the aftermath of this one was anything
like the lack of preparation for the
aftermath of the more recent war but it
meant that the Americans were caught in
ways they didn't expect to be cool